[Music]
no matter who's making America great now
50 years old I'm driving a truck and I'm
gonna be happy because there's gonna be
11 percent growth in the next five years
then all of a sudden bang ups bang
American Express poster service uber
automated you're all fired
what am I gonna do then because I'm
sitting here telling you that America is
gonna be great I'm gonna be good forever
yeah I mean look at that that's going
political like anybody anybody that
thinks the president United States
whether it's Barack or Donald or Bernie
or Hillary is gonna help them they're
[ __ ] loser
straight up I promise you you are that
means you need something I like so like
whether you're whether your president is
for minorities and females or your
president is you know for the 26 year
old white male that's got no skills
here's the punchline the market is the
market what does the 54 year old gonna
do adjust or loose right but how do we
how do we get that message out to say
you know what you could probably Drive
talk to a 55 you can program and tech
and doodle to United talking to BMW they
said that they can't get enough kids to
be to be technician because if theory is
the old the home the old mechanic would
the big grease on his shirt I was
talking to the head of heavy machinery
operations meaning crane operators they
said their jobs are empty for 15 months
these kids can go to school for one year
come out make $150,000 but yet they're
going to a school 50% of them will
retire with the title of a job that
doesn't exist today they're staying in
school for four years happens digital
classes they're leaving with a $300,000
of debt and they still don't know how to
operate anything so how do we get the
parents in this room to save that money
how do we get the kids in this room well
not the kids in this room but who's
gonna watch us online to understand what
they need to do move ahead and nothing
but diploma is gonna save me the
president is gonna save me
welfare is gonna save me or anything
else how do we what happens in what
needs to happen
carnage
carnage needs to happen people are
complacent
here's most people's strategies in life
I mean I really have no passion for this
conversation like if you are not capable
in 2017 to Google [ __ ] and figure out
what's going on in the world [ __ ] you
I'm being dead serious like what role
does the government play or thought
leaders or this an act whatever that
cliche statement of like the teacher
comes when the student is ready right I
believe in that thing like like I don't
know like I'm not lots of things happen
like lots of things happen in life right
I woke up one morning and realize you
know what this liquor shipping law is
never gonna get better there's dirty
politician money they're gonna keep
paying this off and I'm not gonna spend
the rest of my life worrying about what
the right thing to do is and what's
right no they're gonna keep paying off
politicians state by state and because
I'm the biggest I'll always be picked on
so i justed I started over I started
over like I started over like this whole
Wine Library thing and I got so lucky
guess what I own zero percent of Wine
Library because it was under my father's
name sorry no collateral to even start
it started what Boehner media by getting
somebody to pay me eighty thousand
dollars to do a marketing campaign and I
built it and so that's what's gonna
happen and everybody has their version
not everybody has my business talent to
build billion-dollar companies but if
you're making seventy four thousand or
one hundred ninety seven thousand or
whatever you're making and your market
gets [ __ ] I don't see truck driver
Johnny feeling bad for Rick the
bookstore owner cuz Amazon came along
this happened this has happened forever
it's not the first time the innovation
[ __ ] [ __ ] up nobody's crying for the
farmers in Middle America nobody's
crying for the people on Cleveland who
owned the docks this is what always
happens so this is what's up now and so
what 55 year old Charles has to do when
he is out of a job is get another job
whatever that job is so if Charles is
smart and has skills he's teaching
himself something now
to be ready for three years from now but
Charles wants to watch football but
Charles wants a drink at the bar so nice
it is 20% into what's going on in the
future
mr. that's right a bank that you're damn
right I know tens of thousands of people
I know thousands of people extremely
well I know hundreds of people deeply
well there is no correlation between how
much money someone makes and their level
of happiness I have friends who make
$47,000 a year and are the happiest
people I know their work-life balance is
on point they're part of two soccer
teams they play video games they watch
every show they want they take two
vacations that they scrap together and
they're freaking happy as hell and I
know tons of people who I grew up with
in the Silicon Valley boom who have
hundreds of millions of dollars in their
bank account and are is miserable and is
lonely and is broken as you'll ever see
so I implore all of you to please
reverse engineer and figure out who you
are and figure out what level of
monetizing and stuff you need and what
level of creativity need I promise you
one thing one thing that will catch you
very off guard
I should be way more rich I leave money
on the table every day iíve left ungodly
amounts of money on the table
I spend tons of times spending sending
DMS and engaging with people meeting
people randomly and not cashing in I
actually believe the statement I'm about
to make I think that I love the journey
and the game of entrepreneurship so much
that I have subconsciously sabotage my
financial upside to make sure I can play
this a little longer because I fear if
the numbers keep getting too big
eventually it will take the fun out of
it when you were lucky enough like I am
to actually do something that you love
so much do something that puts pressure
against the one thing you care about
besides it which is the time I spend
with my family my family is my whole
life and being this and doing this is
the only thing that cuts into that I
couldn't breathe if I wasn't an
entrepreneur I didn't breathe when I
wasn't an entrepreneur that's the reason
I got these an F since school
cuz I just couldn't be me and I'm not
capable of that and so I think being
here excites me because I think coming
to not LA San Francisco New York London
is always more fun for me it always
feels a little more practical it always
feels like there's a little bit more
chips on the shoulder which is what I
have but I want to remind everybody just
cuz he didn't grow up with a trust fund
just because you don't live in Silicon
Valley the market doesn't care if you're
good enough you will win so when I was a
young kid I made a lot of money selling
baseball cards and comic books and toys
and then I started working for my dad's
business and I was making you know when
I was 22 to 28 I was making thirty five
to fifty five thousand dollars a year
but I had no expenses I didn't go on
vacations
I didn't buy fancy things so I saved my
money I saved my money I saved my money
and then when the tow you know I had
hundreds of thousands of dollars I
didn't have millions and by the time I
was 33 34 when I had that opportunity I
still not bought a home I was still in
an apartment I was 33 years old and I
was renting and because I was saving
cash to go on the offense and so when I
had a chance to invest in those
companies I put hundreds of thousands of
dollars not millions but those hundreds
made millions made tens of millions and
so that's it nothing crazy nothing I
didn't have any crazy crazy advantage
there's a lot of people that make fifty
five thousand dollars a year when
they're 23 the problem is they go to
Coachella and they want to buy a watch
and they want to buy a BMW and I didn't
so I ate [ __ ] for 13 years and then I
had a moment and I struck so what should
we do garyvee let's wrap this up what
should we do what should people do
people should [ __ ] stop complaining
right people should go the [ __ ] they are
good call people should not listen to
America propaganda of fixing the [ __ ]
they suck at they should be tripling
down at what they're good at they should
be competent in certain areas but you're
not gonna become Beyonce or you know
like your bone structure is a certain
way like you're not gonna solve
everything your IQ can get a little bit
better but don't worry about the
incremental figure out what you [ __ ]
put you on fire and your halfway decent
Abbot
lucky enough right now to be listening
and you're good at what you like become
tunnel [ __ ] vision because there's way
too many voices telling you what and how
and here's the other thing and this is
the big one job because you have a
humongous audience the biggest thing
that I've seen dividends from have the
conversation with the person that's
holding you back the reason most people
who are listening right now we're not
doing that thing is they're worried
about the opinion of somebody usually
their mother usually their father and
the reality is is that your spouse may
be the person holding you back and you
have to have that conversation
cut them off we have to get to a place
where you're doing you because the
number one thing that scares the [ __ ]
out of me is regret and you're gonna sit
there at 72 and you say I wish I wish I
wish
and whether that's money or spend more
time with your family there's a million
ways to do this not everybody wants to
buy the Jets not everybody wants a
smoked weed on the beach and Bahamas
like everybody's got a different [ __ ]
thing figure out what your [ __ ] thing
is and stop making [ __ ] [ __ ]
excuses who the president is your mom
did this like like I missed it I had
that idea for uber then why don't you
[ __ ] do it dick 400 trillion to one
those are the odds of becoming a human
being and then I have to live my life
every day on the Internet in my inbox
through the streets of people
complaining the [ __ ] are you complaining
about when you've only got one life and
you actually got one you are more likely
to win the lotto 10 times in your life
than actually having one so can we
please make this video the moment when
you decide to stop dwelling stop crying
don't tell me how you blew your meow in
high school don't tell me that your dad
was an alcoholic it is time to take
control we're gonna see sitting at 80 90
years old in a retirement home
regretting all the things you didn't do
please take life by the throat before it
takes your throat and go out and execute
everything that happened has happened
no more dwelling no more complaining the
only people that are listening to you
are other loser friends so right now
right now wrap your head around this
ridiculous gift that you were given it's
called life
you're using your [ __ ] eyes to watch
this and your ears to listen go step out
and do your thing the one thing you've
always wanted to do or the ten fifty a
hundred things you've always tried to do
because the only thing that's keeping
you back is the other people that are
judging you and who gives a [ __ ] about
them I swear on my [ __ ] kids health
I'm obsessed with losing I [ __ ] loved
losing I love losing because I know
exactly what you're thinking about my
loss and I can't wait to stick it in
your [ __ ] face when I come back I
remember once my grandma said that I was
lazy because after seven hours of
[ __ ] dragging wood in my parents
backyard I was like I need a break
cuz she's old school Russian gangster
and I remember laying there and her
drilling me and me thinking myself I'm
gonna [ __ ] stick it to you grandma
like nobody's ever [ __ ] like I like
losing like when the Yankees and Rangers
won their championships I stopped
rooting for them people like laugh at me
like you're Jackson I love being a Jets
fan
I'd hate being a Seahawks fan cuz you
won it's over the climbs over what do
you [ __ ] fearful of like your sister
making fun of you because she's got a
better job [ __ ] her that's my answer
don't forget my friends you could be
winning 28 nothing at halftime and use
so your older sibling that's got a great
[ __ ] job could be a crackhead next
year could could because he's had a
whole facade the whole time [ __ ]
trying to suck your parents dick
right
and and he's actually insecure inside
and something went wrong at the office
and he starts [ __ ] doing coke on the
side like guys don't you understand how
this is played this is real I'm being
serious
who gives a [ __ ] if you're losing when
you're in college you got any [ __ ]
years to stick it to them bro
I recommend [ __ ] up on purpose I'm
being serious
it's so much better to like eliminate
expectations from the gap then you're
playing with house money if you're
scared of other people's opinion [ __ ] up
on purpose then everybody thinks you
suck [ __ ] then it's all upside huh you
know everybody's like like I'm telling
you I'm not joking by the way maybe
that's what happened to me maybe what
happened to me was because I got decent
naps and every teacher and every
friend's parent thought I was gonna be a
loser
there was no entrepreneurship in the 80s
that wasn't a conversation I'd even know
what the [ __ ] word man the first time
I heard it it meant that you were kind
of like a loser like I didn't do
anything like education was the only
thing maybe the advice I'm giving you
man is based on what happened to me
which was because I suck so bad at
school and that's the only way that we
were graded back then that all
expectations were goose egg for me and
all of it was upside so I was liberated
to play in the [ __ ] machine and just
went on straight [ __ ] off and said
[ __ ] one so go [ __ ] up
[Music]